fire
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby Chin's yelling at us man
yeah she has a full sleeve tattoo and he
treats us different yeah he's got a
tattoo on his leg too introduce Our
Guest who doesn't have Jay Larson like
one of the funniest people on the planet
one of my favorite Comics I remember I
saw you the first time remember I was
like I go hold it I go what the [__]
you're so good yeah he goes it's about
time you [__] noticed because I was
like I I didn't I don't pay attention I
see him on Ryan doesn't murder anything
no nothing I watch him murder and I was
just like oh my God like we as young men
at this point
I'm much younger 10 years ago okay no
yeah it was probably I remember I had
Brian I had this storytelling show
what's up by the way what's up brother
thanks for having me on uh I'm excited
for your special by the way thanks pal I
appreciate it me being me was the first
one and now we have sounds like Bruce
sounds like Bruce yeah Springsteen no so
I do a joke about getting a wrong number
which you know if you guys do did any
research for this you'd know it because
it's gotten over 200 million views Jesus
across many platforms so I'd like to
watch it I uh yeah well you know so
anyway I was just like I had done it on
Laugh Factory had it on theirs and it
got it kind of did well and then Conan I
did on there and it like did well on
Reddit went to number one on Reddit and
then people started like claiming that I
was stealing for myself because I looked
different each one so I just opened the
special on that joke not like clear the
air yeah hey this is my joke this is me
yeah that's great sounds like Bruce so
love it man um yeah early on in my when
I was doing stand-up I was like four
years in I started a storytelling show
at the end
and the whole point was hey I'm gonna
have four comics on I'm gonna throw out
topics and they're gonna share like
stories like your first car like all
these different things it was kind of
like the basis of what the crab Feast
came from right so I'm doing that and I
was like hey it's gonna be real stories
and you know Callan I mean there's
nothing wrong there's nothing real he's
got no depth
no so then I would be like so uh like if
you if you could have any job guys and
Brian's like what if I was a cop what if
I was a cop and I was in the street and
I'm just sitting there going like no
that's not yeah this isn't what we're
doing the show but the thing is he's
charismatic people loved it
sabotaged the whole thing
yeah I didn't know I thought it was all
comedy and it was Steve Byrne Brian
Callan Morgan Murphy and Brodie Stevens
great and after the show ever like
people had a good time you know and my
agents were there and Brian's like that
was great huh I go you know dude you did
exactly what I told you not to do I
asked you to not but you didn't I didn't
know what you will never be invited I
probably didn't listen to you I was just
like
I'm like I don't know what he's saying
well I got up there and I was like a lot
of guys I remember one thing I did like
I saw you looking at me and I knew I
kind of [__] up because like in the
middle I go you know for me obviously
obviously I bench press but most of you
are forgetting this area of the chest so
you'll always see me on a pec deck I
won't even step in with Jim without a
pec deck
Jay who's a pro it's just like you know
dude like this is not the you don't have
to you know what you're doing [__]
[__] I'm trying to like steer the [__]
yeah you know like when I remember never
forget I had a friend who had like an
eating disorder you know and I said to
my mom I go Hey listen when you see her
don't when people have Eating Disorders
you never comment about their physical
appearance you just don't say anything
yeah I go so don't she's like I know
Jason
as soon as my friend comes gets out of
the car we're sitting in the front and
the front comes down the river she's
like oh you look lovely and I'm just
like what are you doing
could you die not just tell you you know
like when there are certain people like
when they like okay don't do this don't
do this
yeah that's me yeah that's that's me
don't say the N word well that's that's
like uh was it Jeremiah Watkins has that
stand up on the spot and let's say do
not do material like this is four new
bits you're gonna find new bits do not
do new material sure enough every show
I've ever been on people before you like
dude that I've heard you do that bit
what are you doing to you oh no not to
me like Jeremiah be in the back he's
like I I don't do that in the main room
oh yeah what are you doing I never Mike
I love that show just because I want to
get on there and drink nothing yeah
throw something at me
yeah it's the best I think people get
obscure you know like a little silence
especially yeah especially even though
you forget silence means they're
listening that's all that means but also
that that crowd knows that's that oh my
God yeah they're there for it yeah
that's what it is all good man
like to see you work [__] that [__] out
like they like to see you like now I do
with my stand-up I always do a section
where I go let's do something wait a
minute how long have you been doing you
you're doing stand up now I'm doing
stand-up now you're doing it only since
you son of a [__]
1967.
um wait go ahead
old enough but I mean how much younger
than you you're older than me 50 cents I
bet maybe you're 56. no you're not are
you really oh man
are you enrolled in the same age as
Rogan 55. he's 56 now I think he's gonna
be 60 in four years yeah it's well
obviously 60 in less than four years
that's who you're friends with Buddy
when's your birthday hell yeah January
26th oh wow you're in Aquarius yeah you
are yeah Wednesday February 3rd baby oh
damn what do you like July or something
you're 15 March you're 15. Pisces I know
I can't [__] with female Pisces dude
yeah but women yeah I can't sorry I
appreciate you are you one of those guys
that asked what sign you are and then I
do now really yeah well now that I look
at my track record yeah you know what I
mean like a high school girlfriend
Pisces Crash and Burn College girlfriend
Crash and Burn girlfriend when I was
living in Venice crash and burned
ex-wife Crash and Burn mother that's all
you need to know all you need to know
her mom was this don't go forward
anywhere else is that right that's mine
my mom's into that [__] all that stuff
like when I was in high school she's
like what's on like scorpions like uh
run I'm like all right Mom yeah I heard
that Scorpios and Pisces are very sexual
and I I will say but I don't think
there's any science to it but I think
one girl who was super sexual and she
was a Scorpio and then she was talking
to her friend and she was like yeah
we're Scorpios we're sexy and I go okay
then and now when I when I hear a woman
is Scorpio I get turned on you know what
none of these things matter because
that's like saying oh yeah we're
Scorpios we're we're circular and then
but these people might be square so
there it doesn't matter how sexual you
are if you don't fit with the others the
other sign it doesn't matter also I feel
like girls just saying that because some
reason be sleuths right
or you can and I'll move you into my
house you know what I'm saying I had to
pay your bills I don't want a [__]
virgin boring I want a sketchy sexual
pass hey dude at your age yeah I'll take
whatever I can get well you can't go
near virgins you know what I mean like
it's probably yeah
unless you're the Dalai well when you're
56 you don't even look at younger women
you don't even look at them you don't
flirt with them because it's you get to
a point where you canceled what was that
too well no but you get to a certain
point when you're a certain age where
you realize they stop looking at you
that way like it happened right at 50 I
think oh you're the chick that used to
be hiding I need the chunky chick yeah
walking by the construction no more
attack calls you're an old man there are
women that like older men but for the
most part you're oh you're dead enough
for the young girls your dad yeah it
might be Grandpa you know like you get
to a point where it was no you just
gotta do the math okay like at 56 young
first of all you're married anyway so
it's a moot point but hypothetical you
know what I mean if you're going to look
hypothetically if you're if you're older
there's gotta you've got to have they
call it date dating age appropriate you
know what I mean so like I'm 47 I'm 47.
you know what I mean so some people
might ten years younger than me
practically yeah some people might think
it's a sandwich but keep going what's
that we look the same age keep going I
mean dude come on don't do them like
that put a ball hat on you maybe in in
at night like at a ball game good angle
in a cave okay
with his podcast I'll tell you right now
if I look the way you look at your age I
am going to be a lucky man you know what
I mean yeah for 56 he looks good he's a
good looking girl always been in good
shape too much yeah maybe too skinny for
me a little too scary but um but you're
the only single one here is the single
life now weird for you
it's not weird like are you jumping on
dating apps I'm on one app yeah I go I
do one app how's that life it's
different you know it's different you
know it's like first of all I have two
kids I have them fifty percent of the
time right so when I have them in three
years I've got a babysitter 10 times in
three years because I'm like I want to
be there I want to be there for bed not
only bet I want to be able at 9 30 to go
in and just see what's going on like
where are they sleeping what what do
they got yeah and then I give them a
little nudge and talk some [__] to see
what they'll do you know
um so it's like you gotta someone's
gotta be cool the fact that you have
kids and it's like their schedule needs
to line up with your schedule I also
have to work you know it's it's a tricky
situation but if you're dating age
appropriate I'm sure they're they might
have kids or they should be used to it
yeah there's a lot of women I've dated
with kids I've found that divorced women
they're like they're like Scorpios
they're like let's get down yeah let's
figure it out what's the time when I'll
be there let's get down yeah you know
what I mean so I think for me
age-appropriate needs to be at least
they have to be at least like 34
anything younger than that is just fine
30 is fine nothing full-grown woman not
for me I mean what are you gonna have in
common with like a 25 year old well
that's nothing nothing they need to be
the most like uh evolved human being and
but normally when you're someone at 25
is into someone at 47 there's something
there's something going on common as you
think I just think I don't know a guy
like you don't want to be the guy like I
it's more like you don't want to be that
guy so let's just it's just unless
you're Leonardo DiCaprio yeah even I see
him I'm not like us creepy I'm like
that's Leonardo DiCaprio it's going to
take a unique person or woman real
Outlaw to be even at like 32 to want to
be with someone who's in their mid 40s
with kids they're gonna have to be like
a unique person like hey I really don't
want kids I think you're a great person
and I'm I've evolved who knows you know
I think it all just comes down to the
person anyway I do too I think sometimes
for the most part if you have a fully
realized person they can be 30. it
depends on how they live their life yeah
a lot of it's like if a woman's gone
through a lot of [__] had a job or if
she has her [__] together that's what
I'm saying they have like their [__]
together they have a career they know
what they want to do you're talking
about different and they know who they
are they don't want to play the games
and they're emotionally evolved and they
also don't want to deal with younger men
sometimes they prefer an older man bro
you see that there's more stability yeah
for sure I just can't imagine like you
going on these dates off whatever app
you're using like coming up with date
ideas and [__] oh I've always had I'm a
dad dude I got great data ideas usually
it's I don't like Dave and Busters and
[__] give me give me an example of great
idea I just go to a nice restaurant like
I need to get to know someone but then
like a good second day for me is like
let's go to a play it tells me early on
are you into art and culture are you
going to want to do that let's go to a
museum those are the kind of things I
like to get down on that's great and
then you know there's only one woman
I've dated for a long time throughout
these three years which was like nine
months and we would like we would do
like weekend trip to Ojai you know we
would go to cool places like explore
together go for bike rides I got her a
bike for Mother's Day you know Jason
sounds like a good time Jay sounds like
a good time it's not that hard let me
just tell you one thing if you're single
out there all women want is for you to
make a plan at a time and a date and
tell them where to be that's be not what
they want and be nice well I mean dude
that's a given you're a whole school
that's what I like about you know your
old school Irish Boston yeah let's take
a little break because you know the NBA
playoffs are here and you know this my
Denver Nuggets number one seeds yeah
dude nuggets joke it should be MVP but
they're going to screw him over and give
Tim bead not a big deal I'm not bitter
at all but listen the NBA Playoffs is
here and it's time to make some Bank bro
with DraftKings an official sports
betting partner of the NBA get in on the
excitement of every game with a touch of
a button new customers can bet five
dollar pregame moneyline bet score one
hundred fifty dollars in bonus bets if
your team wins plus everyone can score a
no sweat same game parlay every day
during the NBA Playoffs open the draft
game sports with app opt-in plays the
same game partly on any NBA game if it
doesn't hit you'll get a bonus bet back
up to 10 buckaroos Again Lakers aren't
bad right now against Memphis they won
the first game if A.D stays healthy bet
big on Lakers Sacramento is a fun series
you got the the Knicks is fun to bet on
Celtics are always good during the first
round you got Milwaukee I'm taking my
freaking nuggets all day over the Suns
if they get to the Western Conference
Finals either way download the app now
sign up with the code fighter new
customers combat five dollar pregame
moneyline bet and score 150 in bonus
bets if their team wins only a draftking
Sportsbook with the code fighter
gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler and
Massachusetts call 800-327-50 or
gambling help stop lining.com org and
New York call
8778 Hope and why and in Kansas call
1-800-522-4700 on behalf of Boot Hill
Casino and Resort uh 21 and over is in
most eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction eligibility restrictions
required see draftkings.com Sportsbook
for details and stay specific
responsible gambling resources
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp now look uh I grew up in a
family where therapy was considered to
be taboo a weakness a weakness and all
that stuff you get older and you realize
that's the day that was right but not
anymore now it's okay to talk about you
get over it you get older and you
realize you don't know your own brain
sometimes you don't know the source of
of your anxiety or the source of your
depression the source of your angst or
whatever it might be so your family and
friends might not have the answer it
turns out they're not professional not
licensed professionals so if I want to
find one Brad better help we'll have to
go in an office you don't have to go
into an office you don't have to spend
that much money you can there's a
there's a cheaper option that's just as
good better help
is a is a basically an app where you can
be paired up with a licensed therapist
in as little as 48 hours and you are off
and running you've got somebody you can
actually talk to you can switch
therapists if that one doesn't work for
you if you've gotten a number of them no
additional charges it's entirely online
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule if you're
thinking about starting therapy give
better help a try all right discover
your potential with better help it's
entirely online visit betterhelp.com
fighter today get 10 off your first
month better help your old school Irish
Boston yeah and by the way that's a real
thing you grow up if you're Irish in
Boston you grow up with a very very
clear sense of what is okay what's not
okay what what is allowed what's not
allowed how a man behaves and how a man
doesn't be is it still that way in
Boston yes she gets smacked in the head
I mean I would think I I really don't
know Tick Tock didn't ruin that I mean
who knows I don't you know my friends
everyone I grew up around their kids are
amazing kids I can't get over how great
my friends would you ever go back to
Boston I would love to but it's probably
not going to happen at this point yeah
well when you're Divorced with kids you
know it's like I want to be close I live
eight minutes from my ex you know what I
mean so like I have her over for dinner
she comes over all the time I have a key
to her house you know what I mean like
it's just a weird segue to Boston you
see the new documentary on the Boston
bombers on Netflix no oh it's good I
know my [__] on that stuff I love that
stuff why is that I watch on the
marathon just happened today yeah the
marathon's today that's probably why
they released it on Friday the woman who
won it is their second Marathon she's
ever run what Jesus she won it today
from Kenya yeah well she runs the 5 000
meter and this is the second Marathon
she's ever run and it was like it was
like a small pack with a mile left and
she just so there's a there's a there's
a Highland area of Kenya
or less and that is where the the people
there's a there's a genetic anomaly in
those in that group they're good at
running they're the way they're
physically built they can run farther
than anybody
my son's pretty good at running this guy
was a cab driver
he was driving a cab within a year he
broke the world record he didn't run
before he was Kenyan he got out of his
car and he's just a horrible cab driver
though yeah it took forever also I don't
I wish they'd keep it you have to be
from Boston in order to run the race I
want to see the best runner in Boston is
yeah you know there was a woman who ran
the Boston Marathon one year and she
like dipped out at Mile six hopped on
the subway yeah and came back in and won
you know yeah where are you from in
Boston Stoneham Stoneham Mass 15 minutes
north yeah that documentary is great
because it had [__] in there because it
has like
like citizens uh videos of this like
when they're in the shootout on the
streets in what Waterfront or Watertown
I've died right yeah Watertown oh well
one of them died because uh during the
shootout and they have the shootout
they're the the footage of the shootout
bro it's the cops shot over 200 bullets
the dock has actual footage of it dude
they're throwing bombs at the cops
that's why I gave them away because they
just thought it was two kids that stole
a car because they jacked their car with
a guy in it now he had stolen car they
didn't know it was the Boston Marathon
bombers and then once they start
throwing bombs they're like these are
the [__] guys so they're throwing the
bombs the younger brother gets in the
car his brother runs out of ammo and
he's you know I'll get to his brother in
a second his brother starts and they had
thawing videos but it just starts power
walking towards the cops going come on
come on of course they're like get down
get down the little brother gets in the
car runs his older brother over kills
him why just to get away
because his brother was basically doing
suicide by cop and his brother's like
[__] it he's in the way runs over him
gets away hides in a boat like a block
away yeah hides in a boat but here's
what's crazy the the older brother
he started being compromised going back
to Dagestan and this is what's weird
there's a coach on this channel
but there's a there's a coach on there
in Boston because his older brother was
a very good amateur boxer his his whole
goal his father browned America to fight
in the Olympics for America but the
Olympics changed the rules the year it
had nothing to do with him but he
thought it was racism towards Muslims so
that's when he became compromised he's
like oh the Olympic Committee hates
Muslims America hates Muslims no no dude
there's you have to be from America born
in America to fight for the U.S team
that's all it is but he thought it was
like towards him so that compromised him
but the coaches talk on there and I'm
I'm watching I'm playing like I know
that [__] guy from somewhere I
trained with him in Boston when I was
there for the the no yeah I trained at
his gym yeah wow
oh my God and then his coach I think
coach against me when I thought Gabriel
Gonzaga because Gabriel trained in
Boston I was like that's how I [__]
know that guy I did uh I performed at
Auburn University the day of the bombing
the day of it really and I did like you
know I was doing an hour for these kids
and after like 45 minutes I go hey do
you guys just want to talk about what
happened today and like I said on the
edge of the stage and just like like
what do you like what are you feeling
like what are you going through you know
what's interesting like obviously it's
you know it's an American staple the
Boston marathon's massive it's like you
know it's as American As It Gets in
Boston you know when it represents but
you know four people died in that you
know there's it's weird to me like what
we get what the media gravitates towards
off they gravity towards that but it's
like you know Louisville Kentucky had
two mass shootings more people died than
that yes yeah you know like the mass
shooting in Chicago you know just today
more people can get shot yeah and die
than the boss of America now they're all
important it's just weird like this has
a dock obviously it's a good you know
the the narrative people can run on well
when you look at terrorism right it was
Muslim terrorism it was terrorism
after 9 11 and terrorism was the biggest
thing you know I think it was
politically correct on HBO but he said
something that was so true he said man
Americans we're all worried about
terrorism it's definitely a problem but
that's not what's going to kill you
what's going to kill you probably and I
hate to tell you guys is your diet all
that question like the next day after no
no it was about a year later but yeah
it's different he was just like the the
enemy is usually not as not as sexy the
enemies we can control that right right
but that's scary because we can't
control that's right we can't control it
and fear cells you know fear cells yes
not me yeah
terrified of everything yeah got me yeah
yeah that whole thing's interesting and
then the little brother right he gets uh
he gets apprehended after like five days
one of the biggest man hunts in U.S
history he gets apprehended and the
defense goes well he looked so much up
to his older brother like that was his
Idol he was forced to do it boy did they
eat him alive because they have him send
them there's no one tell him to do he
sets the backpack down next to a family
with a kid that kid dies he's the
eight-year-old kid got blown up and
they're like nobody told you to do that
then they show him in this the on the
dock they show him after the bombing
going like a 7-Eleven he's like joking
around like buying candy and [__]
sodas like this kid's a [__]
sociopath man How old uh is their kid
now still in jail
oh he got out Brian of course he's in
[__] jail he's the Boston Marathon
bombers yeah I do yeah he's at the
maximum I don't think there's a death
penalty in Massachusetts uh see but
that's on the dock it said uh he tried
to appeal it because he got the he got
life sentence they appealed it I think
they gave him the death penalty hmm
I think
okay he got his own Wikipedia page
what's interesting about this kid's time
what's interesting about this kid too
super popular like his friends when they
said it might be him they're like no
there's no way super popular Captain the
wrestling team like had his [__]
together was going to college like it
was just it was just a normal dude yeah
like super popular too
damn complete deal fade when the
government refused to rule out the
possibly death penalty
um
apparently because his brother was like
The Mastermind the charges of usage of
our weapon of mass destruction resulted
in death in addition to aiding
abandoning
eligible for the death penalties yeah so
yeah I'm pretty sure he's getting the
death penalty
it's crazy yeah horrible thing
he got uh like yeah the jury recommend
death penalty
there you go the court reversed the
first circus decision reinstating the
death penalty yeah he's on he's on death
row now okay and he said I'm pretty sure
is he stationed in uh Colorado where
Gotti was at he's in like maximum
security he's [__] damn man rightfully
so yeah Colorado there you go
those parents they move your kids they
they do everything for them you're
boxing you're in the cabinet wrestling
team yeah we don't know that no the
parents weren't cool about it you don't
know this the parents weren't cool about
it they weren't no they're like that's
not our son that those aren't even
that's what I'm saying yeah he's what
Brian's saying is they went to this
great extent to give these kids
something and this is what they turned
in yeah that's what I mean they must
there's got to be a gap there
no no that's what the the mom and dad
said so the dad was super like strict on
him because he wanted to do a fight for
the Olympic team in the term
professional so his dad wanted to be a
boxer they made it you know they made it
seem like America was against him so
that compromised him but it's weird
because his dad escaped Refugee like his
grandpa was blown up in war over there
and then his family think about those
parents you lose both your both your
sons in one day like you lose them both
and you're you probably take on the
guilt of all those people that were
affected by the bombing and then the all
of it then the shrapnel effect of how it
affects people around that Community
yeah well they even have no no positive
they have the head Muslim guy on there
and he's like it's like it [__] us when
he didn't say that that's my words but
he was like it [__] the of course the
rest of the Muslims we just got over 9
11. and when we he and that guy saying
that he goes when I saw him like please
don't be Muslim dear God please don't
and that kid would attend his church
damn it they said his mom mosque yeah is
that crazy yes
the biggest piece of [__] is the older
brother's girlfriend
and she knew about it she refused to
speak to the the to help out the US
government when they're on the run and
they know she had she was aware of it
and everything but they couldn't bring
the charges on her biggest piece of [__]
she's some American dumbass that's too
bad
Chill Vibes though guys I love that I
love what we're getting into oh yeah so
tell us about your special yeah so great
yeah let's talk about it is that crazy
that documentary's [__] great though
it's really really good unbelievable are
you in any shows right now besides
Marathon no I got into shrinking a
little bit I started shrinking have you
guys watched that at all oh no but I
heard about it with uh Harrison Ford and
oh yeah I saw that he plays a shrink
yeah him and Jason uh Siegel I never
liked uh
I never liked shrink shows I don't know
why this is different I don't know I
think it's I like it um but there's
nothing that I'm like crazy on right now
did you see the one with uh what's the
[__] face he's in um he's in the
Anchorman
um he's also um grew
oh Steve Carell Steve Carell see him and
he's a shrink in the he he's working
with the serial killer yeah
oh it's good oh yeah oh it's [__] I
gotta see that I love it it's great what
happened they didn't do it was it just a
one-off thing well no you can't do a
season two one okay you'll see the
ending but yeah so it's got that kind of
like uh tradition the idea that it's
just like you want to see he's like well
yeah he's like the head uh like the best
uh you know therapist in in the town the
serial killer comes to him you can't
tell him everything he's doing he just
wants to help him and he makes a
connection with him and then he's like
in order for me to actually get help I
get to tell you that I'm a serial killer
so he kidnaps and puts him in his
basement he's like I'm gonna let you go
once you help me like figure my life oh
wow that's wild and then he's killing
people while he's helping him out it's
nuts Steve Carlos he's trying to get
away Alyssa yeah I'll ruin it for you
know what I mean any opportunity for me
to see these things it's been out too
long no I got to see it though I got to
see it don't no I'm definitely gonna
watch it I need a sear I need a show I
haven't had a chance but by the time I
get my kids to bed it's like when
they're finally asleep like 8 30 and I
usually go to bed by like 10 30 and I
gotta like do some dishes or I gotta put
the laundry on you have like one episode
maybe of something maybe you know what I
mean and then I get up in the morning
and I'll like do my meditation get my
day going get them off to school and
then it's like all right let's get work
going you know what I mean so you
meditate yeah I do TM yeah yeah was that
trans uh Transcendental Meditation what
does that mean how do you well TM as you
you basically you meditate twice a day
20 minutes each time and uh for me it's
it's giving your brain an opportunity to
have its own thoughts and do whatever it
wants for 20 minutes you know that's one
of the greatest things I was able to
teach my kids that I never knew my sense
my son said something to me one day and
I go listen I go one thing I want you
both to understand I go your brain is
separate from you your brain is its own
thing it's not you your brain can have
thoughts doesn't mean those are your
thoughts that's your brain's thoughts I
go now it's how you act upon what your
brain thinks that's good that matters
who you are and then I explained to them
like my kids know I meditate they'll
come in while I'm meditating and I they
I explain to them I go this is my
opportunity to give my brain time to do
what it wants so that I can focus when I
need my brain that's interesting I want
to play this I want to get your take on
this keep talking keep talking that's
well that was it but I mean I mean do
you want to do a follow-up question
can we meditate for 20 minutes no I saw
something I like just um
no I saw something I like did I play
that for you that Muji thing you know
Muji Muji yeah no who is he I I'm too
old to get taken by anything and it's a
simple I doubt that is it an app no no
he's a vedanta teacher he teaches uh
it's really should are you speaking
English right now yeah uh guided
meditation with Muji mugaku
and I I like I think the thing that's
interesting about meditation is all
different methods there's all different
formulas it's all different you know
um I just I like you know put it this
way I was a David Lynch fan and I'm like
he's huge into TM Seinfeld's our TM when
he was 17. worked out for him yeah and
uh so I just I liked the premise behind
it of like giving my brain an
opportunity to do what my brain wants to
do
it's tough to find 20 minutes with kids
though
it's not so you can do it because listen
all the [__] you just told me you
watched in the last I don't know
20 minutes in the morning 20 minutes in
the afternoon once you just make it a
priority well most of it's on a flight
or at night when I put the flights is
easy see this is the thing I was just on
a flight and I just you know what I do
I'm like
I want to watch uh something I already
know I'm that's my biggest problem I
like the comfort of watching something I
like I'm similar but if it like I only
watch like murder crime [__] yeah like I
love serial killer stuff with the boss
Marathon I know about it yeah so I I'm
the same one I have a routine I know
like I know the story so even if I doze
off I can pick up I'm not lost yeah
they'll play that super boring thing
couldn't find it thank God no it's not
boring actually it's a little bit cool
dude give us the recap of it uh well he
says something to the effects be a
witness to stop trying to be a traffic
policeman in your own mind
just let it run and and be a witness to
it well that's a giant part of like most
people nowadays in uh
you know if you look at anything
anything in the addiction space whether
it's booze drugs sex spending money uh
food most people in which and which is
like why that everyone could get to
Trophy idea is is that like we don't
allow ourselves nowadays enough time to
sit in uncomfortability we don't allow
ourselves time to just have thoughts
that might not agree with what we want
and I think a lot of times it's like
people need to get comfortable with that
just like kids need to get comfortable
with losing they also need to get
comfortable with the idea of things that
aren't just going to be the best that's
why I can't stand dog owners nowadays
remember when you were a kid dogs
weren't even allowed on a couch now
people bring them everywhere they sleep
with them it's like hey you don't need
to get love from an animal 24 hours a
day my sister's dog if you weren't
holding it'd be like
what did you do to this poor animal yeah
you got it believing that code to get
help yeah 24 yeah that's a good point
yeah that's very true yeah but I think
that what I'm getting better at is
getting very like so no matter what's
going on right stress anger uh anxiety
whatever it might be I'm getting very
very good at literally kind of just
stepping back and watching it getting
really interested in it like I'll
literally interpret the raw data of it
so I go like I I'll go deeply into
what's it's actually doing physically my
body and when you do that what's
fascinating is it goes away like you you
actually you're acknowledging it well
I'm also just a witness to it yeah so
after a while you start to realize that
your life in many ways like this is
profound but think about it and I'm you
can this is kind of how you can meditate
when you're going through your life your
life is basically a movie
there's somebody watching
this and it's not you that the most
profound question somebody asked I think
it was Sam Harris who said but it's a
vedanta question where are you do this
exercise where are you right now like
where are you watching me from
think about that but really think about
it what do you mean where do you start
and where do you end you are you behind
your face so you're watching me right
yeah you know what's a great point
because I love where you're going with
this because I've often said like as I'm
sitting here looking at you right now
I'm like what is he seeing how what are
you looking at I don't know what my face
looks right now I know what yours looks
like but I don't know what you're
looking back at me and when I walk into
a room of people I never take the time
because we're you're in the present and
I'm looking out what is everyone seeing
at me you know what I mean especially
since you know like you're worth it from
I see from right here this is yeah but
that's is that where you are I'm present
right now I've read this great thing
that people you know 80 like I think
it's something like 85 of your brain
lives in Nostalgia it lives in the past
but like I saw this great Alan Watts
quote the other day that there's no past
there's no future there's only right
this SEC like this second is the only
thing that exists all that happened all
that it hasn't happened yet that's what
anxiety comes from anxiety you build so
much of it up that's why I love the idea
if you just sit back and can watch your
own life because you don't so often
don't well your brain was I think it's
interesting is your brain can actually
be a witness to everything you're going
through
so you can go be going through the
craziest [__] your brain you you can
watch there's a part of your brain
that can watch
anything that's going on with you you
the pain you're in you could be on fire
and your brain can be watching it for
sure so when you see that those monks
that put the light themselves on fire in
protest and they don't make they don't
make a sound they just roll over and die
they have they have literally detached
from what you would consider yourself
and they're able to watch themselves
Burns that's insane that's another level
it's another level yeah of course it's
like 200 to put themselves on fire well
that that would be just give us the
secrets but everybody watched that and
what was that fascinating was they went
that guy didn't move he didn't scream he
just expired and fell over like the
[__] and those words he was
watching himself
um
that reminded me of something I was I
was trying to think of of what the [__]
you can't stop Wars anyway bro no no
it's 2023 in 2022 Russia was like yo
we're gonna go bomb this country we're
gonna go and we're gonna do this and the
whole world was like man I guess we'll
just watch they don't want to get
involved yeah no but it's just like it's
crazy I mean we are involved the
question is when do we want to get
involved oh we'll get involved later and
we'll just get well we're involved we're
involved more than we think
yeah that's a whole nother Road and are
we losing or are we winning who did that
where I mean did you see that thing I
sent to there to our group chat yeah
tell it B what you said right yeah
it's pretty interesting wait I just
remembered what I wanted the recap
Branson to Texas here's hey here's
what's cool did you see Ethan Hawke when
uh Steve Colbert asked he goes Ethan
Hawk what happens when we die it's his
question
that was a good question he goes what
happens when we die bring up Ethan
Hawke's answer it's pretty cool it was
awesome I uh yeah I definitely saw it I
[__] loved you doing the robot voice
no it's it's it's it's like Hugo Ethan
Hawke who I I've been a fan of for a
long time I'll just play the audio Yeah
that's the it's the short one
yeah
you ready
I don't think that we have uh an
understanding
of
the Divine concept of time
I don't know I don't think we're any
more capable of understanding it's on
The Late Show
and um so
I don't think I have the intelligence or
the DNA makeup
now real quick I thought you were saying
Stephen Hawk Stephen no no no Ethan
Hawke you know the actor yeah okay
Stephen Colbert like a purge seven [__]
no but the thing is I think you're
talking about Stephen Hawkins that's why
I said are you doing the robot voice
like no I know you're talking about it's
even hilarious because he gets asked the
same [__] I thought Stephen Hawkins I
something physicists come any closer
than that you know than than Ethan Hawks
yeah I don't the guy from Purge I don't
I think the point is that the guy from
Dead Poets he died from training I ever
tell you the topic I watched it on the
plane yeah yesterday yeah but I tell you
that's a theoretical mathematician who
answered one of the great theorems that
like one of the questions of the century
it's like a mathematical question his
name is I did a podcast with him
it was like I couldn't understand
anything he goes well we uh
mathematicians and physicists don't
believe there's actually a thing called
time what he goes it's a relationship
between two mathematical bodies but
there's not time the way you would think
is like you get older it's not that's
not that's not what's going on
oh character expand and then he went
into you can't I mean did you ever do
senior advanced math in high school I
mean how far did you get in math
Remember When numbers stopped coming to
a a correct number that continued I was
like
Russian the Russian guy one of the
fields medal of math he goes they're
like how should we teach math he goes
well the way you guys think of math what
you think of of math is it'd be like the
way you're taught math in school would
be like we're gonna teach you art and
the way you're going to teach right is
you're going to paint this fence over
and over again if you're like I don't
like painting a fence over and over
again it's [__] [__] that's
exactly how they teach math because math
has nothing to do with that interesting
yeah he goes it has everything to do
with the world of forms it's the most
beautiful did you did you do a debate
with uh Alex Jones this past weekend yes
I was how did you know that yeah I was I
was sorry we're friends right it was me
Alex Jones [__] I know he's in the sake
of the podcast I didn't but I like to be
dramatic because of how the good
question I had I had
I had Destiny on one side of me who is
the streamer the left wing streamer
who's really popular very smart keeps
the right very honest no guy my name's
Destiny yeah Destiny's Stephen his
streaming name is Destiny smart smart
smart guy only 34 too oh yeah dude oh no
he looks smart and we'll take it to you
by the way
he and Alex Jones I had to get there's a
thing about it because I had to get in
the middle of them I was like whoa whoa
whoa Alex let him finish his sentence
that's a big dude Alex over here he's
Giant and he's over here I I I I agree
with Alex in general but he's just so
theatrical well it was about three
speech because it was weird it was a
really I was in over my head bro I got
there they invited me it was about free
speeches you've been in over your head
here yeah thank you thank you I am I'm
always over you know see you're you
you're not using your vision you're
using your brain well it was about the
Twitter files and it was about but I had
a there was a free speech constitutional
lawyer there's another these people live
and breathe that Alex Jones we know they
released those those Twitter leagues to
get more to cut down and more freedom of
speech that's the agenda I think Elon
Musk wanted to release him to show you
how bias this organization was but keep
going but what was fascinating was that
the question came to this and I kind of
learned something and Alex Jones I gotta
say I gotta say the man
said something that at the end of the
day so here's my question to you guys is
there any case to censor information
malinformation disinformation Al-Qaeda
domestic terrorism that's trying to
spread that give information recruit
people
you wouldn't censor that because we
don't censor it necessarily we should we
do okay we should if it can hurt
Americans physically we should say what
about racism
imagine you uh but the the Privacy the
my thing is is racism can lead to that
stuff but if you can shut down
domestic terrorism or even International
terrorism that's going to hurt Americans
we shouldn't allow them to have a
platform when it comes to race them that
opens up a whole lot of doors because I
think there's racism where it's clear as
day right using the end so let me ask
you let me let me play some Magic yeah
get that [__] out of there but at what
point do you say all right well we stop
it here so let's refresh let me rephrase
the question we everybody agreed on that
panel that anything illegal anything
illegal is it should not be allowed
right so exciting violence the doxing
people uh
um
it's Jay
so but but anything illegal child
pornography doxing people that said so
Alex Jones is like any of that stuff
illegal I'm talking about racism I'm not
talking about any of this stuff I'm
talking about in ideology would you make
it would you censor it would you not
Alex you mean Alex said Destiny said
there should be at least a a body a
governing body at the companies and with
the government that says oh man that's
tough Alex said Alex said absolutely not
okay he said that and so then I said to
all of this panel because I was in over
my head I said are you the me the I was
just there I mean I was with these
people but these people live and read
this stuff yeah I know and I said well
here's my question if you have an
election
and somebody's very good at planning a
story
uh and and they are able to sway the
vote at a key time in the election like
Trump in Russia yes or whatever it might
be
what do we do about that and Alex Jones
said you let the people decide and he
said you let everything fly unless it's
illegal you let everything on the
internet because what happens is we will
all learn figure it out to be careful
and we will get and then it will spawn
an industry of of people we trust legit
journalists to verify or not I can't
agree with that that to me is where I
came down no one you're giving way too
much uh
uh you're assuming that there's people
just smart enough to do that what do you
think the whole there's customers
founded on that concept I'm not saying
that this isn't right I'm just saying
like uh assuming there's so many dumb
people out there that are just looking
for a story that aren't going to
investigate further and who do you trust
anymore for the news I don't know
right it rise to the top where you'd say
we know for a fact if it comes from this
you know this company that's what you
but what is yeah maybe someone's gonna
have to go but now there's none of them
where would you go now like CNN I get
the [__] out of fox no way yeah we know
they're both compromised yeah of course
I don't know where you turn well you'd
have to have someone come out you did a
business what would happen is Fox for
example I'll give you an example like
with this whole
um Dominion thing they're in deep [__]
because right and and what happens is
people go hold on now that you've been
sued you're going to a process of
discovery we get your your emails see
your phone stuff and everything so now
text so now it turns out you guys hate
Trump you guys thought he was full of
[__] the campaign official Trump's
campaign official was like uh the audit
looked pretty close to the count we're
like hold on wait a minute you were a
trump campaign official you were you on
Fox were were peddling this and you
didn't believe it yourself so what
happens is their market share goes I
don't know now advertisers where they
make billions of dollars a year
advertisers jump off that's quite
transparency is important but Cena's
doing the same thing of course they are
so if you're on the left you're watching
them
how are they how are their ratings doing
yeah CNN they ate a dick but where can
you go where you're gonna have someone
in the middle well you know where you go
crazy people like Russell Brand Joe
Rogan breaking points also the best yeah
and that's but that's what I'm saying is
that if you allow the marketplace to
work you will find people and because
over time you just recommended it
shouldn't be up to Russell Brand who was
a comedic actor somebody else now but
it's not that's not what he wants to do
either it's not Joe Rogan to give you
the news maybe Russell Brand
I think mainstream media for the most
part you can make the argument for the
most part it's going to get a lot of
facts right not interpretation but facts
oh I did that Monopoly comes to
politicians because when you say a
mainstream me to me like CBS This NBC
they're all compromised I'll play this
for you this is great this is this is
from Matthew so Matt Gates is a
republican Congressman okay and he's not
a guy I necessarily I don't know much
about him at all but but this is a guy
who's been in Congress for he's been
elected four times he's been there for
you know so he's an entrenched
Congressman you see him on C-Span all
the time okay he he's he's as deep uh
Washington bureaucrat as possible listen
to what this [__] says
the way this place
I think the lobbyists were on the show
most of the times I think people are
more interested in servicing their Pac
fundraiser than they are the needs of
their constituents and it's a grift game
and the way that what facilitates that
grift game is an entire sophisticated
structure that ensures that no one's
really responsible for the legislating
right if we had to take individual votes
on individual departments and
authorizations
and bills and spending then we would
probably be be held to account to a
greater degree by the people in this
country but instead what you get is
every year or so some multi-thousand
page bill that you get a day day and a
half to read and the whole deal is
thumbs up or thumbs down on the whole
thing and then you're left with the
decision of you know voting for a bunch
of don't agree with or leaving out the
widows and the orphans and the veterans
and the military and things that every
American would care about and we had to
force upon the system a better way to
deal with legislating as an Enterprise
and that had features in policy features
and personnel and features and procedure
and that's what we're working through
yeah it's also like duh right right but
it's interesting that that somebody in
the system is calling out themselves and
he won't win something he'll be
ostracized for that
where do you get your news from like if
you want to like read about whatever it
is I don't you just don't you stop you
just I I just I've just been uh in the
last three years to be straight up with
you I've been focused on making sure my
kids are seen and heard and loved and
cared for and I get my sanity and get my
life in order so to me to give a [__] I
mean bro I'll be straight up I've gone
to Iraq and performed for the troops
I've done it in Kuwait I've done it in
Qatar and I and I do it because I'm like
oh I think this is great for the troops
but I think it's [__] horseshit and I
don't like any of it and I look at our
politics and government and everyone I
know there's like your vote counts and
I'm just like I just don't think it does
it's so [__] tied up in so much
horseshit that I'm just like you know
what I'd much rather do I'd much rather
just take my kids to a park and when
then they go to bed I'm gonna do the
laundry and I'm gonna get make sure
clothes are done and then I'm gonna try
and figure out jokes to make people
laugh because all of this [__]
I know I would love you know I'm just
not as informed as I as I could be you
know what I mean I get it I get it I get
it because you know it's exhausting it's
just if you get too deep into it's
exhausting well so you realize how
little you can't do much you can do yeah
yeah you have so much although I gotta
say Austin for example is a hotbed for
generally like just uh self-expression
and politics you've got you've got
anarchists you got capitalists you got
social it's just like a whole group you
got the comedy scene it's a very very
vibrant scene right now oh yeah of that
Boston that's America it's America's
best because Americans are just having
it out in conversation Yeah Yeah well
yeah you went there to host that well I
was there at the mines Fest thing the
audience was like yeah in other words
like they were like they were Alex Jones
fans Destiny fans then people just
shaking their heads going with you know
it was like it was just an American
Forum because the crowd was getting into
it Alex Jones would say something like a
[__] and then I said he's a
conspiracy theorist and they're like
you're being a jerk and I'm like I'm
just saying I didn't mean I was just I
was being oh dude I was being you know
dramatic I think a lot of time too it's
whoever's gonna Scream the loudest and
whoever's gonna bark the the biggest
bark they're gonna get people to hear
and they might not be the most informed
and the most intelligent and the most
yeah well let's arguing like Trump won
right what's that that's the argument
what Trump won I mean it might be yeah
oh
it's current events oh let's get into it
hey B let's take a little break you like
nuts in your mouth don't you I love nuts
you like big juicy nuts I I do love big
juice like the bigger than that the
better in your mouth look I'm a fan of
almonds I'm a fan of pistachios no yeah
but I like I want something more buttery
I want something rounder I want
something with more of a full sexy I'm
talking about macadamia nut I'm talking
about Mac and put our Elon Musk that
wasn't so expensive they're so expensive
I can't afford macadamia nuts unless I
knew of a company that actually worked
with them now see Farmers you're talking
about House of macadamias I'm talking
about House of macadamus bro om how much
do we eat these they're here in the
studio all the time they didn't start
off as a sponsor well we these are dip
macadamia nuts this is the raspberry
white chocolate the chocolate's great
the regular macadamia nuts are great I
like these nuts in my mouth look there's
only nuts I put in these in these lips
look at my skin dude I'm 75 years old
and if it wasn't from macadamia nuts I
wouldn't look 56. here's the bottom line
you want to look 20 years younger you
want to live 20 years longer they're the
healthiest most delicious nut in there
they are also the lowest carb of any
popular nut 33 percent less than almonds
50 less than cashews and they are
arguably the best fat profile of any nut
like an avocado on steroids okay they
have they have more monosaturated fat I
don't know what it means but I know it's
very sounds good no listen macnam nuts
are known as the most expensive nut and
often hard to find but House of
macadamus is changing that and bringing
the power of them Macadamia seven fatty
acids dude that supports natural
collagen production glucose metabolism
and it reduces inflammation they have
thus been linked to longevity and fat
loss so shut up they even have an
amazing omega-6 to Omega-3 ratio which
is three times better than that of
pistachio I don't know what Brian's
saying I'm bored as well as you guys are
listening they taste delicious they're
good for you House of macadamias has a
major range of products no added sugar
artificial ingredients from hand sorted
nut with Savory all natural flavors even
dipped in sugar-free chocolate my
favorite Macadamia bars yes it's a super
ridiculous right
uh listen they never do discounts but
just for the final kid listeners they're
about to give you the power of the
macadamia nut house has a very special
offer use the code tfak for 20 off your
order for limit time they're giving the
list there's a free bottle of cold press
extra virgin Macadamia Oil worth 20
bucks yeah dude put it put it on your
legs you should see where I look like my
torso and you know a thin conservative
sheet of uh extra version
dude let me tell you something do prove
it let me tell you it's it's perfect for
cooking given its high smoke point and
buttery flavor yep try cooking with it
so you can get that uh cold press extra
virgin Macadamia Oil worth 20 bucks when
you visit
houseofmacademias.com
tfak that is 20 off these delicious nuts
in your mouth and you get a free bottle
of cold pressed extra virgin Macadamia
Oil worth 20 bucks when you visit House
of macadamias
macadamia nut on I need one
okay let's get into some current events
man
Georgie you want to do this so Joe had
an issue a warning after a artificial
intelligence podcast
using his voice using everything it's
literally like a two hour long Joe Rogan
Experience all AI modeled and he had to
put out you know a statement saying
watch out for this you know
yeah it's insane I you know what I know
someone who I think you know this person
made a stand-ups comedy set by Tom Brady
you know that no was that the rumors
that Tom's doing stand up because I was
going what do you say after that rumor
came out
someone has an AI software that you know
created a stand-up took pushed into it
all Tom Brady interviews and all these
other like clips of him speaking and it
spit out an hour-long stand up set by
Tom Brady and the person that I know
that listened to it said it was good I
got better reviews than mine God damn oh
dude it didn't even God it's you know
Reddit didn't go bad it's crazy what AI
I mean it's just insane well they even
did it with uh the weekend in Drake they
took you all the music they do they put
it into chat GPT did a song it's a
banger and then someone posted it and
it's so good and they're like musicians
and [__] let me hear it Brian called
this so early on too it's gonna be like
you're gonna just have to make a
decision that if you want to like
you know did you hear there was that a
what was it there was this like AI
generated thing that had to hire someone
it had to it had to do something
you know like you know like when you go
through at the end of like signing up
for something on like whatever Amazon
like what are the traffic lights and you
have to click the traffic lights you
know I mean that's a blocker for like Ai
and there was like some computer system
that like got to a block in like this
program that they tested it and it went
on Craig uh Fiverr hired someone to go
do the thing that they couldn't do as an
AI and had a person do it and pay them
so that the AI could get through it you
know it's it's it's going to be up to us
to say like oh yeah we just want to
either support because you can just use
AI to replace graphic designers if you
wanted for your business you know and
stuff like that about Hollywood it's
about writers
there's already programs I mean so
obviously I have to cut this out just in
case you do yeah okay oh yeah
it's pretty [__] yeah but you still
need Drake the bottom line is oh here's
the bottom line not only with whatever
AI is going to create but our our entire
Society is so watered down by people
just everything's water through some
filter thing that people are gonna love
this kind of stuff at the end of the day
before that because because they're just
watered down anyway what's this this is
the AI Joe Rogan
so I just paid just a little bit of it
ladies and gentlemen
that doesn't look like Rogan who the
[__] is that
I'm your host Jonah road again or at
least that's what this AI model thinks I
sound like The Cutting Edge AI link
sounds exactly like
yeah I'd be like hey what's going on
with Joe Rogan I'm like Joe I knew he
was a robot
Sam's been at the Forefront of the AI
industry well you get the point pretty
much but it definitely doesn't look like
Joe Rogan
the voice though it's actually it's
pretty you can imagine how still how
good it's well that's Chad gbt4 now we
we are going to be dealing with chap gbt
100.10 yeah so when you have Beyond musk
and those people going hey we need a
global pause yep like when you have when
you have it there's so many the
technology is going to either liberate
us kill us or both kill us yeah yeah I
mean put it this way of the day do you
like to go out for a hike in the woods
and be around nature and like swim in a
lake yes you know so it's just going to
come down to like you making a choice of
like what do you prefer do you prefer
going to like live music and I mean
actual live music or do you wanna just
be a part of something because I
guarantee you half of that [__] Drake
song the people aren't into it because
they're into the song they're into it
because they're into this idea that AI
did it and then they're into the idea
that all these people are getting into
it and they don't want to be left behind
this idea and they feel like they're
like oh I'll just I'm gonna be part of
this conversation I I think it's it's
just pushed the native more making uh
Americans especially softer because now
like if we're gonna live in that VR
world this chat GPT world not a real
world you can look however you want you
don't have to go to the gym anymore you
can get a six-pack just by creating an
apple I know you know it makes everyone
soft think there's no consequences I I
think no distance the one thing that
might save us a little bit I don't know
if you'd feel this way but like when
you're on YouTube when you're on social
when you're on your phone too much
you just junk your brain I need real
fight your brain needs real food well
yeah but you guys are also born before
the internet just I don't think so I
think even kids because kids are
actually shunning it a lot of kids are
like I can't do this like a lot of kids
are aware my daughter the odds would beg
to differ be really the stats would say
completely different yeah especially
suicide through the [__] but that's what
I mean is like kids are starting to even
see oh this is not serving me this
ultimately feels good but it's not good
for me and I think that's what kind of
happens I also think it comes down to
the same thing it's like it just it's in
your house what are you doing in your
house how much you connecting with your
kids what are you exposing your kids to
what do you allow them to watch what do
you what do you what do you exposing
them to as a parent what do you bring
your kids to you know what I mean but
now you're talking like a dad and what
is the thing like the leading cause
mental social behavior is fatherlessness
the leading cause of suicide among kids
is fatherlessness those kids never have
a father enough my kid doesn't I didn't
have a dad you didn't have a dad nope
turned out pretty good yeah well I mean
you know that's why you're such a good
dad well yeah I mean I lean into it
hardcore yeah no my kids don't have
iPads no mine either yeah I saw a study
on like we're getting rid of those we
never had them yeah they had them for a
little bit just maybe when they're
eating lunch they'd watch you know
whatever that [__] stuff like the
kid stuff and then when I saw this study
this extensive study over 10 years of
kids that had iPads and kids that didn't
and the learning disabilities the kids
had that had the iPad and just my social
network dude I was like oh we're getting
rid of them I can't imagine anything
good my son's nine my daughter's seven
this never had an iPad never had an
iPhone never gone to a meal at a
restaurant where they watched the phone
ever they have work they have school
computers you know what I mean that's
different though yeah yeah but those
don't it's not like they get to use
those at home or maybe sometime over the
weekend my son has a switch he's only
allowed to use it over the weekend and
he's never using it for like you know
hourly Clips at any in any capacity we
go to museums my kids draw they my
daughter the other night she was bedtime
she's like she's all bummed out I go
what's the matter she goes I wish I had
more time to draw and I go you want me
to wake you up early and she goes yes
get me up at five
I go I'm gonna get up to meditate at six
I'll wake you up at 6 30. I usually have
to wake them up at seven to go to school
yeah so I go in at 6 30 I go hey she's
like I go it's 6 30 do you want to do
some art she's like
cover off at her desk drawing my son
walks to the kitchen breakfast table
reading a book he brushes his teeth
reading a book nerd alert no that's cool
and it's great yeah no I love it but
that's the thing with iPads is it it
shuts down their creativity so that yeah
so of course when you're bored when
you're bored as a kid and you're with
your brother like me and my brother we'd
either go outside play sports you're
forced to be creative yeah you got to
come up with ideas yeah but you have an
iPad just steals all of that like when
you're on your phone you're not coming
up with new bits on the road no dude
it's stealing you're creative camping
when we go camping I'm like we're going
camping this morning going to Joshua
Tree you just wait do you guys Camp no I
grew up camping you go camping with your
kids you will see a completely different
human beings than you see in their
day-to-day life are you kidding yes you
go to Joshua Tree yeah we're going to
this weekend we're going Friday Saturday
Sunday coming back that's great they
have like cabins
the first time we went camping they [__]
in a bucket really yeah out in Buellton
yeah
dude I was camping with my kids and I'm
sitting there I got my daughter on my
lap and we're looking up at the the
stars and at the time there's in
Buellton Mars was out Venus was out we
saw the International Space Station go
by and I was like guys look at this I go
look how big the Moon is compared to us
and I look up the size of the Moon the
size of the Earth and then how far it is
and then how big Jupiter is and then how
many Earths fit inside Jupiter can you
videotape your experience next time so
me and my kids can watch it no and we go
through all this and then my daughter
just goes my daughter was five at the
time she was Dad I know what she goes
this is it's overwhelming me like just
even having that and I think not only do
we like uh cool I think sometimes like
you know when you give kids space to
just have thoughts on their own just by
like talking to them like as an adult
you'd be really surprised at like what
they're capable
damn yeah it's a disaster what else you
got you let me just check Tick Tock for
a sec Brian I'm surprised I feel like
you would be more into this kind of
stuff I am I'm just not I'm not do you
guys play board games I mean I um well
your kids are older so you may miss that
window yes my son loves to play chess
and backgammon oh man Elon with this BBC
journalist yeah this one I threw it out
I said you might as well set me to do
this interview this guy was not ready he
was and he was like well no there he's
like well give me an example you know 52
million views this guy got roasted
I contributed to about 200 000. are you
really hold on a second Brian are you
really surprised that on Elon musk's
social media platform that he owns his
video got 52 million views that's so
mind-blowing to you 52 million though
that's how I can't believe in my house
my artwork is all over the wall but
that's kid's favorite that's hate what
is it but but you know how this came to
fruition is the the BBC was like we'd
love to interview Elon because they
thought they were gonna like get one
over him he goes open door policy
anytime you want to come so the guy
comes on and outs here's I want to speak
to Elon they grew up dealing with y'all
sit down with them unprepared whatever
he's a guidance whatever he wants get
the camera out oh this is good that's
how it went go ahead
well it's a long ass interview but oh
just the clip on the on Twitter if him
blowing them up hold on can we pause it
this is exactly the problem with where
people are getting their news from this
is a clip from a clip and we're gonna
watch a shorter clip of it to then show
how he got roasted sure dude it's funny
you're right we're just sitting here
you're like yeah you go to Rogan and
Russell Brand and you go to these other
people and all they're doing is getting
a clip from a clip or a clip and then
putting it in the platform that fits
yeah we don't have time though did you
show us a little bit
the fact that this BBC journalist and
there's a narrative and he doesn't even
know what he's talking about well we've
said this already that all these New
Jersey like it's very rare to find
someone who's well educated knows what
they're doing yes so there's a shorter
one that George sent me this is the one
I posted
to limit it
self
distributed
I'm not saying anything um
but you've just said
did you say
um
wait can you stop for a sec what do you
mean when he says I don't use that feed
what does that mean in Twitter I'm
saying he's not he doesn't use Twitter
he doesn't use his private his personal
feed anymore he's like I've seen him
he's saying that as he's saying I don't
yeah it's confusing he [__] up because
he goes I'm seeing more hateful comments
on there anyone goes well so he doesn't
look at his feet
I mean well so then Elon goes but Juan
you just said you see more than ever he
was giving an example he goes well I
don't look at he goes well doesn't make
sense you just said yeah keep going well
it was I mean it was the day Elon took
over the n-word was used more on Twitter
in that day somebody say so they say
right they were I saw a bunch of posts
because you know I follow certain feeds
that show that kind of thing but I will
say this let's also not forget that this
dude from the BBC even though he's got a
BBC handle and he works for the BBC he
himself is just trying to get yes
attention and likes and Views by going
back you Ambush him set him up because
he thought he was going to come out and
he's going to do this thing instead of
being like let's get a meeting let's set
it up let's do our problems and
everything yes
I agree and boy did it backfire it's
like did you think you were gonna be
smarter than the guy who owns this is my
favorite part he could be smarter if he
had any research and done any
information it's like when you watch a
stand-up get up and you're like oh you
haven't developed this joke at all you
haven't dug deeper into it yet you
haven't like found the next move in the
next move that's why you watch the great
people like oh they they they do the
boring [__] of sitting down and chew
it down and chew it down and chew it
down let's see but most of the people
with these talking points if you grill
them they wouldn't so on Saturday Night
Live when that Megan Kearney she goes
the first time
she's the non-binary yes which is like
I'm not going to do anything I'm a big
chick from Cleveland but uh it's kind of
a great show it's a great troll I'm
non-binary that way I get like we talk
about it probably that's what's going on
I don't know but but uh here's where she
goes uh you're against health care for
kids for Trans kids no excuse me uh no
it's about
being against gender affirming care as
you put it for Trans kids first of all
you don't know if they're trans you know
why psychologists don't know because
their brains are developing their
parents don't know and you know who else
doesn't know the trans kids yeah and but
what you're saying you want to castrate
children and have double mastectomies
and give them drugs that sterilize them
that's what you're that's what you call
that's what you think is going to stop
them from committing suicide if they are
trans that's what you called your
[__] Healthcare get the [__] out of
here so if you Dr Grill them I love when
you grill people who have this narrative
that takes on like a snowball and it's
like it stops it right in its tracks
that's to Jay's Point nobody's doing any
of the research looking into it so we
don't have the facts so everyone's based
in their assumption off clicks right and
shortcut versions of it well I don't
know how the rest of that interview went
you know yeah
you do two hours yeah
I bet he gave him a half hour tops 45.
yeah I wonder how it and I wonder how
the very end was
is this just the is it was it a full I
think it was a full interview but he
kept wanting to change
the subject and then yeah but what
happens do you want to finish this then
no this is just a clip this this cuts
out give me an example I can't you just
lied
yeah it's great what else you got then
what up how do we get on oh this is the
whole uh see this is where back to like
what you said real quick about
non-binary or not identifying I have
people in my life that don't identify as
male or female as they identify as they
them and they want to have surgery to
their body and they're an adult
and do it their parent or their the
person that
their parent
doesn't acknowledge it can't even fathom
how old are they they're 21 years old
can't fathom it and and so what my core
thing is when you ask me about the news
or my thing and when I'm just like all I
give a [__] about is making sure that I
take care of my kids to create
loving nurtured human beings so that if
anyone ever if my kids ever came to me
and said I'm gay or I'm trans or
whatever it is an adult age that I'm
able to just support them and hold them
like I got your back I don't care what
it is that you want I got you back and I
love you I disagree with you I totally
disagree with you because let me tell
you something that 21 year old or a lot
of these people do you think they'd have
these conversations and have this thing
where what something's wrong with me if
the trans ideology hadn't gotten in
their heads well I don't think I wonder
what would happen I don't think the
bottom line is I am saying the
what I'm saying is that what I'm saying
is that there are a lot of people who
have issues with their life they feel
confused of course when you're young and
you're trying to make sense of the world
you not only are you confused but a lot
of times you will you will go to
extremes it's how our brain is it's how
I was a lot of kids when you have enough
social contagion and enough of a support
system for an insane ideology you are
going to take that ideology on why for a
thousand Reasons one of which might be I
belong to this group now
it makes me unique now ones might be
it's so extreme maybe it'll change
everything because I don't like myself
self-loathing not liking yourself being
uh dissatisfied with who you are is part
of being [__] young and the fact that
we have an industry now which makes a
lot of money supporting the mutilation
of your body which I don't believe is
going to necessarily in a lot of cases
make you not kill yourself
so with don't touch touch the kids but
let's say it's a 25 year old 30 year old
and they still feel and there's actual
people out there that identify as a
woman I'm not going to stop yeah do your
thing it's just when you go to the kids
is where I'm like let's wait you know
the guy who believes in two genders like
I'm a guy who believes that your gender
correlates to your biology and I make no
apology I was transfer through you male
and female but if you were trans if you
come in and you're trans if you're if
you're a man who transitioned to a woman
and you want me I'm going to refer to
you as she I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm never
gonna make you feel bad I don't get off
on that right so and by the way I'm also
going to protect your ability and right
to do that but but I'm but but I don't
believe then and if you want me to call
you a woman I don't believe you're a
woman but I'll call you a woman but now
here's where it stops you want to fight
for biological males and female sports
go [__] yourself you want to fight for
making letting kids make their own
choices on this go [__] yourself I wish
you were passionate about this
it's my red lines
it's bad for kids yeah but I'm not I I I
I think you made a lot of valid points
things that like I and I love that you
have a stance on it what I'm saying is
at the end of the day you know I think
the most important thing you can do
whatever you're filling your time and
your energy with if you are a parent is
just being there with your kids love on
them give them discipline I'm not saying
baby them give them discipline let them
know they're cared not try and solve
their problems give them the ability to
solve their own problems and
hopefully with all that all that pain
and anger and hate and self-loathing
won't be at the surface I mean it maybe
it's way down a little tiny bit or maybe
they'll only have 10 of them that way if
they did come to this this realization
that maybe this is something that they
needed to do for themselves transition
or come out as gay they they know that
there's a loving environment to do it in
and they're doing it from a place of
like hey this is who I am not a place of
I want to be a part of something you
know what I mean yeah and suicide's not
an option because they have the support
yeah yeah of course suicide man yeah
well do you know the highest rate of
suicide so among transgender people have
experienced generative dysphoria is 42
or something now think about how high
that is yeah 42 this is what's actually
20 of all people that so so
transformation typically people who have
this gender dysphoria this notion that
I'm in the wrong gender the real people
not the people that are I'm not no not
the people on Twitter not Demi Lovato
I'm talking about people who actually
are willing to go through this surgery
which is a major thing maybe the girl
from Juno they have a 42 suicide rate
after now now listen after you're saying
uh well no they don't know so they don't
know that that there are a lot of people
D transition a lot of kids are
de-transitioning like coming back a lot
and when you say kids what do you mean
what age I'm talking about kids who went
on puberty blockers at 14 13. that's
fresh when they come back senior Dave
to have a stock clinic right in England
had to shut down from their thousands of
lawsuits because a lot of these kids
were autistic nobody tells you about
this this is like the equivalent of
lobotomies but at the end of the day
um the what was I talking about before
before we said transgender 42 oh yeah so
42 right so check this out so that's a
higher suicide rate than people in
concentration camps during the Holocaust
and during slavery where American black
slaves were under bondage human beings
in bondage they didn't come close to
that suicide rate and you want to talk
about who's doing the [__] stats then
can I just ask you real quick in between
[__] getting that caught and you give
me your uh suicide you're suicidal they
have those stats because they gave they
have those stats the average life
expectancy well they know who killed who
killed themselves so so they don't know
who's having suicidal either way they do
so so the Holocaust is very clear
records on that people I know exactly I
didn't see listens I could easily see
Hitler wanting to know those stats and
initiate that from assigned but I can't
I just I would love to see where you're
getting the information of slave owners
being like yeah I talked to a good good
chunk of guys
the science and Skype out of town so
historians and Scholars if the suicide
rate was anywhere close to 42 among
American slaves it would be you're
talking about something we all know so
you're saying that the current rate on
trans is 42 that actually follow through
with it not wanting to do it so you can
have that stuff now that's what I mean
want to who actually do it do it now
that's such a high rate that's why
people are trans that's why people are
trans activists who want to nip it in
the butt right there like the people
that actually really care are saying
this is unacceptable which it is right
do you know who do you know who the only
other group that comes close to 42 who
has roughly the same amount of suicide
this is kind of crazy Majors no not
close
paranoid schizophrenics oh wow so it's
it's uh well it's a weird thing right so
it's like worse so you understand that
if you are if you do really have genders
for it which is very very rare it's a
very rare thing and it's almost always
male healthy less than one percent way
less way less way less but it's ushered
in this whole gender well what is the
percentage of people doing it now so
it's called social contagion the way
anorexia was and bulimia was among girls
Jordan Peterson said all the
psychologists knew the literature was
very clear that you are going to create
a mass confusion among young children
especially girls already ostracized
already uh uh emotionally and mentally
uh unstable how so well you you have
children who already have their loners
they're Autistic or whatever it might be
they already have they're already
imbalanced psychologically yeah this is
part of adolescence this is part of
middle school and stuff like that and
they have a safe all of a sudden you
look free at home all that all of a
sudden you create
uh an epidemic you create a possibility
that this is what's wrong with you yeah
and I I just have experience with this
because I have children when they go on
Oh I thought you're gonna see your
anorexic
what what I would support that I'm too
shredded we know that and I don't know
you're not like healthy skin no but I'm
shredded they're too skinny
[__] guys
I'll do that I'll give you I like I mean
blocked block blocked ah damn it but
anorexia muscle muscle
going it's been a heavy podcast
back to Jay's special
you got any happy stuff for more people
dying I don't think there's much happy
stuff out here right now that's the news
chair that's probably the problem where
are you getting your news
oh here's a happy one oh this is Ed
Sheeran he did concerts I think in uh
Brooklyn and then there's this Subway
singer who's like an older black dude he
sings Ed Sheeran songs all the time so
Edward Ed Sheeran surprised him and gave
him tickets so I wish I was on that
train I was on the Atlanta training
let's wait for the advertisement hold on
let me write this down
[Music]
everywhere else
he wasn't that surprised was he well now
I expected him to be crying all stuff
but yeah
[Music]
everywhere I look I feel to you
with mine
[Music]
I
don't know
that's the worst episode of American
Idol I've ever seen Jesus Christ I love
that all he did was give him tickets
he's that guy who's like he
he's like you're doing nothing with your
life man what do you do with your life
he's like just sitting there with his
hat on like that and he goes I'm doing
music because yeah doing music and he
goes no I'll show you some this is
grandson and you guys go what are you
gonna show me he goes I know you're like
prince I gotta I gotta I gotta player
same favorite song dude he plays Purple
Rain
The Grandfather's like you see him like
this he goes like this and he goes then
you see him go
[Music]
he loved it
yeah and then he gets up and has to walk
away I was like whoa he couldn't even
have feelings that kid was so good the
guy the kid is so good you're like oh
you keep transcription huh what what
okay just trying to tie it all together
yes you know what's one of the greatest
things about the Sandler Special 100
fresh have you seen it yeah the Chris
Farley tribute well I mean that's great
too but when he went and he just
performs in subways and just like push
it in Subway that's a great I think
that's it you didn't watch 100 fresh no
it's just like one of the best stand-up
specials in the last 10 years yeah it's
great easy it's so great wow we keep
watching The Tick Tock with the grandpa
uh what else you got I guess we can end
with this one
in your wedding yeah I'd be excited
that's Mother Nature baby
that is so awesome
it's just nature you [__] that's a bad
home and hot or a good one well that's
why that's how you know what kind of
wedding party is they're like oh my God
mine be like yeah look at the guys
how do you know by the way we also saw
12 seconds and we saw two seconds of
their reaction right that's hilarious
you see the gay cameraman go oh my God
who's the guy next door
that's probably the guy that that's the
officiency yeah officially he's the one
who's getting is he the Moose Wrangler
Joe stolen that guy ain't gonna Wrangler
moves no no we had a bear at our
campsite when we were camping in Ojai it
was about from here to the wall
seriously yeah so I'm like sleeping I
got my son on one side my daughter on
one side and then I hear the people at
the campsite next was going oh you know
you're supposed to yell at a bear and
make loud noise right so the bear leaves
their campsite comes over to ours and I
like wake up from them yelling and I
open the window to my tent and he's the
Bears right there like a brown bear
black bear it's a talking about it I
think it's a I think it's a black bear
probably they're good size it was a good
size yeah and the the guy who runs the
campsite had told us about the bear
ahead of times like every now and then
if you leave the food he's just gonna
come in it's not a big deal so I'm just
like hey get out of here my son wakes up
what's going on look at the bear I got
the flashlight bear looks those and just
Slumbers away just goes to the next
scary though
I'm in I'm in Wyoming camping big
whiskey Mountain Grizzlies Grizzlies
Grizzly tracks and so my girl and I are
sleeping in the tent she has her period
and she grows and she I have never seen
a human being more afraid
she was like I'm bleeding I'm bleeding
oh my God oh my God because Grizzly
smell that and they come and kill you
and I've never seen anything like
clients I want to look this up because I
so then check it out I'm not gonna dump
that now I got her in my arms like this
I'm 20 but you died I'm 22 and I'm
sitting there and I go the only way I'm
gonna get her to calm down is I go
that's a myth who told you but I knew it
was true I go that's that's period blood
yeah I go if anything it repels them
because they can smell human she goes
how do you know I go because I read it
I'm into this stuff I'm the one who
knows about animals and I had I can't
believe that word
I was terrified hell yeah even though
it's all complete [__] my buddies
can't I go I need to borrow Uganda
because you're not part of my God I'm
calling Mommy yeah if you scream I'll
shoot it I go [__] you you're gonna miss
and go through me bro I gotta get a new
tent today for this weekend I want to
get like a I want a big one I want like
a five to six person too yeah you're a
small condo yeah I want a big tent
there's some cool things [__] Ted I
spent 13 hours in a tent when I was
[__] doing meat eater because there
were gale force wins no there's real
tense though now is the tent industry is
way different yeah I was in a good tent
I'm in Alaska in a [__] tent still
small yeah it's still made of like I and
scale Force wins I don't know how to do
anything with a tent man like [__]
right
yeah I'm like uh well even Rogan I was
like do we have any caviar though
next to me I can hear her the coldest
fog thing these big lips
you can just hear him put in gear I was
what [__] what I'm sure he goes
hunting below
do you want to or just can't no I've
never hunted many of them no only two
um
but I wouldn't be opposed to it at all
you know I love the idea of it that's
why one of my favorite scenes in the
history of movies is in Deer Hunter that
scene when he's just got one bullet and
he's chasing it like tracking him and
truly hunting and like like me against
you is like the radish thing of all time
I wonder if they really killed that deer
for the movie because it I'm almost sure
they did that looked like a real shot of
a deer can you look that up Jen I'm
almost sure I mean it wouldn't be
inhumane you can deer hunt especially
last time I saw a deer actually get shot
on camera I remember I was like okay
um no I haven't ever gotten into that
you know I was raised by a single dad I
mean single mom you know like there was
no
she's not hunting we just started
camping through Boy Scouts yeah where
was your dad he just never he was just
the town over bro
he was yeah and did you have any idea
growing up he's just yeah so he bounced
when I was young and we'd see him up
until I was I was like 10 and then we
just never saw him being a dad can you
how it's it's Unthinkable can you
imagine just dipping out on your kid
right now oh [__] what no bro but I I
will say there are some circumstance
when you look at like how hard it can be
fine you talk about people commit
suicide people commit suicide over
Finance you could easily just be like
well [__] you know like my mom and dad
did not have a good relationship and
there was constant battle over money
from him to us you know what I mean they
could just get to a point where he's
like it's just too much and I also know
as a single dad who has a full-time job
my amount of time that I have I mean I
have my kids 50 of the time I would take
them 100 if I could but you start to
look at how much time you have in your
life he might have just been like you
know who knows you know I've never been
so toxic when you or your mom and him
he's like this isn't gonna be good if
I'm here still like I'm doing my kids I
don't think that's what he was thinking
you know I was trying to help you yeah
but I feel you there might be those do
you know him now he's dead I mean I saw
him when I was 36 and then he passed
when I was like what did you have a
conversation with him yeah he went when
I was 36 yeah yeah I started emailing
him when I was 24 and then we would
email for years and then finally at 36
he like asked to see me and I went like
spent like eight hours with him and had
like a really cool day he gave me [__]
really and uh so I have stuff in my
house from him and then like we emailed
after that and then like when I had my
son he was talking about like maybe I'll
just like come to LA and like I could
just be near you and [__] like that did
you forgive him yeah I did because he
didn't ask for it I made that decision
right I think it was just like I started
looking at it and just being like you
know you can't ask anyone to be perfect
and if we're truly going to live in a
world where people deserve second
chances I have to like
give him the second chance I his name
was Norman and I tell my kids I'm like
well Normie you know like that was your
that would have been your other
grandfather you know and they're like
they know my story with my dad and
they're always just like I never forget
one time my daughter was like bummed out
about living in two houses and she was
talking to me about it and we were
talking about she was a little upset and
I'm like yeah buddy I go I bet that's
tough for you to have two houses I go I
don't know what that was like you know I
never had to I was I had one house and I
never really saw my dad and she was like
upset and she just goes oh that must
have been so hard for you oh good kid
and I was just like wow wow it was
amazing that she could like have that
realization social way of saying I love
you Dad well she has no problem just
saying I love it but that's great yeah
it was cool
um it's so strange man I wonder I guess
he had his own demons he had his own
things going on and as an adult you can
sit back and be like I wonder what was
he was dealing with I mean yeah I mean I
do a little bit because he would tell
him like about his relationship with his
dad his dad by the way uh was a
physicist you know we were talking about
that earlier at Harvard and sophomore
year got pulled out and worked on the
atom bomb in Los Alamos oh wow under
Oppenheimer yeah wow I have picture
Polaroids of the first atom bomb like
the men holding it yeah crazy stuff [__]
so check out the big brain on Brad Jesus
I know right yeah he was a smart dude
and he came back from that was like I'm
done and became a baker like his his
father or grandfather was a baker yeah a
lot of a lot of math and bacon bro then
was your dad uh Banker too or no my dad
was a musician my dad and my mom were
both musicians in college that's how
they met and then he got out they lip
they had a baby they had a baby like in
college and then they had three more
like quickly and so he was teaching
trumpet you know he's a music teacher
and he won yeah banging with it
he wanted to be uh he wanted to be an
antique dealer but he loved Antiques and
what an eccentric man like antique like
Trumpets like money digging those
professions he and my grandfather did
really well oh I bet we didn't [__] so
he was a rich kid
I he wasn't really like I think he my
mom thought he was a rich kid my
grandfather was smart with his money and
exposed him to a lot of stuff like my
grandfather was the kind of guy that
would like go to watch like the symphony
or Jazz and then would wait in the alley
by the music musicians entrance and when
they came out was like let me take you
to drinks because he just wanted to be
around that's cool so uh yeah and then
so my dad worked at the bakery never
wanted it and then this was an antique
deal the rest of his life so he he was
uh so interesting like he knew not a lot
about silver coins yeah a little bit he
was super into like we we both are like
this it was crazy because when you start
emailing someone that you never knew
yeah and then you realize he writes the
way you do he talked away like we're
both transcendentalists I consider
myself a transcendentalist you know and
and that's the way he would write like
I'm like oh my God like
he loved Emerson I loved Emerson it was
crazy Emerson's awesome he missed out on
you he missed out big time I feel bad
for him to be honest he missed out on me
I had two great sisters a great brother
how good you are at Stan you know what's
crazy so when he died I was doing the
Today Show in New York right and I got
the call from my brother who never calls
me my brother just I'm not joking you
don't have a relationship or we do it
he's just well he doesn't call he just
doesn't talk on the phone he doesn't
FaceTime and he called and I picked the
phone I go who died and he goes dad and
I was like oh [__] because he knew that
I like kept in touch anyway I left New
York went to mass called my aunt or had
someone else call my aunt to see if I
could get in touch with his wife my
dad's wife and I went through his art
studio and then I went to his apartment
went through his apartment and uh weird
you ready uh printed out on the printer
was uh
the
not tickets but the
the website from like Mohegan Sun I was
doing Mohegan Sun Connecticut and I was
printed out and he was gonna go I don't
know if he's gonna go but he saw it like
I remember you know damn that's close so
like I have I found like old emails from
him like where I printed them all out
where he talks about like telling people
around the antique store about me so
like he you know he just was dealing
with when I went to his apartment I was
just like holy [__] that was for this
guy hated himself yeah hated himself it
was just like living in squalor my aunt
was even telling me she's like you might
not want to go it's like really sad and
I was like no I want to go and it was it
was maybe
problems when he finally died oh yeah
well my brother called and I didn't cry
and I was like he's like you okay I'm
like yeah I'm okay and it was like you
know you guys are married you know and
my wife even though we're divorced is
like a very special person to me and she
was even more special to me then she
still will always be you know like after
my two kids she's the next most
important person in my life you know
um and as soon as I called her she
picked the phone
what is going on and she just sat there
and then I was able to get it out but
like it wasn't real till I could tell
her almost you know you cried for the
father you didn't have in a way you know
right yeah you cry for a lot of it well
it's it's still like it's like you're
saying you know you're just connected
you know biologically and emotionally to
that person you know but you probably
wouldn't have been a comic or any of
that stuff maybe without a dad right or
oh yeah I mean this is the thing that
people just don't get about comedians
there are some comedians I was talking
to a buddy of mine who's a comedian and
I have I'm [__] up and I know he's
[__] up and I'm like yeah there's
certain people like that are the anomaly
and I brought up a comedian I like who
just aren't [__] up and he goes bro
I've been on the row with him he is
crazy yes I go really and he goes beyond
anyone I've ever he goes I've been on
the road with him and said to myself oh
I'm normal and I was like no way and
there is not one and this is we're all
Misfits it's the crazy thing about
comedy is that
people want us to be comedians despite
what were what we had to go through to
get to that point and then there were
comedians now that are working that were
watching them we are watching some
comedians they're like oh they're going
to be dead soon yeah and you just go to
their show and they're killing and
everyone loves them and their agents and
their managers are rooting them on go go
go and they're we're all watching them
die yeah we're gonna watch them train
wreck yeah it's insane yeah but you know
in a way thank God because they're
hilarious I mean it's I don't know is
there any other way to be there is there
is a way to like there is that like you
know uh hey if we gotta lose a thousand
men to save a hundred thousand you know
so if we got to lose one comedian to
bring joy to Millions well it's a weird
job we have we're all it's the weirdest
craziest thing in the world bro I don't
know if you could be funny without being
a [__] up and like you know well you
have to be able to like just stare I I
followed a comedian the other day at the
store and I was just like they crushed
so hard and I was so impressed that it
like who was it Ali Wong oh yeah she's a
monster it was just so real and so
truthful I'm like she's on fire and I'm
sitting there I'm like what do I do here
what do I do because we're in like
similar situations we're both divorced
and she's talking about but she's
talking about in a way that I can't talk
about and uh I'm like I had to like
leave the room you know what I mean
because otherwise I was just like so
entranced and watching it was so good
and then I was like all right let me
just like try to roll off of what she
was talking about and I rolled it into
my own way and it it allowed me the
space to talk in a way that I've never
allowed myself to talk before and I was
like I hit her up after I'm like yo you
were so amazing today I go thank you so
much I like you inspired yeah and it it
was you see your show her Show's good
everyone's saying it's beef ever won a
movie no it's a seriously I heard it's
amazing I haven't had a chance to check
it out people absolutely love it she's
so crazy talented bro so talented but
she says stuff so then I would say some
stuff and people like oh and I go see
how different it sounds coming out of my
mouth versus coming out of alleys yeah
like you know when a short Asian woman
is saying [__] about she's telling the
truth oral you know what I mean you're
like oh [__] and then if if I were to
say that oh straight white it's just a
completely different thing it was
amazing to see it and be able to comment
on in real time like because we just
watched it we all watched it together it
was pretty cool that's a great thing I
mean I think like comedy clubs are like
the Last Frontier of like a place where
you can all go and especially when
you're in like a a showcase environment
like that because you can go off of one
POV to another back to another and you
know when we're talking about freedom of
speech like that's like where it just
like lives yeah it should you know yeah
so they can see your new special on
YouTube April you say 19th April 19th
yeah Jay Larson comedy April 19th ladies
and gentlemen Jay Larson appreciate you
Jay yeah I appreciate you guys the best
man that was awesome thanks that's it
kids
B you got something coming up soon
helium uh April 20th 21 22 I think the
First shows on all of them are sold out
and I think Thursday might be as well
but there are still tickets left for
Saturday and Friday thank you uh you
know what that's from 1999 Photoshop
[__] is that a lot of Photoshop is that
check and it's not you down here
Stress Factory
yeah yeah sorry oh yeah Comedy Zone uh
May 4th to the 6th Stress Factory May
11th to the 13th all right kids love you
Jay thank you man you got it go watch
your special